ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes como ha dicho javier en mi
nombre es nicolás avedon y soy escritor
de ciencia ficción y tenéis que hacer un
escritor de ciencia ficción aquí en la
ventaja de ser escritor es que mi
presentación va a haber pocos números y
pocas gráficas
lo malo de salir del último es que ya me
han pisado casi todos los ejemplos
como escritor mi especialidad son los
futuros distópicos y la inteligencia
artificial con consciencia propia pero
antes de ponerme a hablar del futuro del
siglo 23 voy a hablaros un poco de cómo
conocido la inteligencia artificial mi
primera vez con la inteligencia
artificial
a finales de los años 80 yo era un
adolescente de 15 años que me
relacionaba mejor con las máquinas que
con las personas poco ha cambiado mucho
la cosa
el caso es que en aquella época antes de
internet existía una red de ordenadores
llamada ácido net no sé si alguno puede
que la conozca finalmente existía antes
de internet y era una red de básicamente
de aficionados que montaban unos nudos
en sus casas de forma que se conectaban
unos con otros a lo largo de todo el
mundo intercambiando mensajes y ficheros
bien yo a finales de los 80 tenía una
bebés en mi casa en casa de mi madre y
mara no lo sabía y recibía llamadas de
personas a través del modo de la línea
telefónica para conectarse a mi bebé ese
para descargarse ficheros e intercambiar
mensajes con otras redes del mundo y
también porque no para hablar con el
inciso es operar el encargado de la
bebés
y bueno pues hablaban conmigo y me
costaba menos relacionarme con la gente
en aquella época el chat era algo
innovador no es como ahora que estamos
todos acostumbrados en aquella época
había una vista de una aplicación en mi
bebé se llama lisa elisa es el primer
sistema de inteligencia artificial
conversacional diseñado allá por los
años 60 no os vayáis a creer no era una
versión evolucionada era la misma que yo
ponía esa aplicación en mi bebé ese y
los operadores creían que están hablando
conmigo los los usuarios pero no están
hablando con elisa y os tenéis que
imaginario bien en cuarto oscuro sin que
mi madre se enterara veía la gente
hablar porque se veía hecha se veía las
conversaciones de los usuarios hablando
con la inteligencia artificial durante
minutos a veces cuarto de hora y hubo
usuarios que nunca supieron que no
habían habla conmigo
habían hablado con una inteligencia
artificial
así es como convence con inteligencia
artificial ha pasado el tiempo ha
llegado internet y district convencido
que esta imagen no suena familiar esta
foto es mía la hice yo hace poco en un
restaurante y bueno yo supongo que mi
abuelo diría se van a quedar tontos todo
ya con el móvil no sólo era esto el caso
es que yo veo algo más que esto yo veo a
cuatro chavales que probablemente se
conozcan del instituto que están ahí han
quedado para cenar pero a la vez están
hablando con otras personas en todo el
mundo están compartiendo cosas están han
salido de su zona de habitual yo
recuerdo que con su edad estaba comiendo
pipas en el parque quizás con unas
cervezas y intercambiar cosas con los
compañeros de clase no había no había
mucho más donde elegir sin embargo estos
puestos chavales cada uno con sus gustos
con sus aficiones con sus cosas raras ha
conectado con gente en todo el mundo de
hecho no lo digo yo lo dice el informe
pills que dice que la juventud de hoy
escribe y lee más que la nuestra es que
resulta difícil de creer y podéis pensar
que que no es lo mismo escribe por
whatsapp que escribir cartas pero los
datos están ahí vale
en internet que como podríamos decirle a
nuestra bisabuela pensando en vuestra
bisabuela que es internet
le diríamos que internet sirve para
comprar zapatillas en amazon le diríamos
que sirve para el periódico le diríamos
que sirve para
no sé una recoger cita se integrase de
eventos como este le diríamos que sirve
para alquilar en un avión o para ligar
con internet porque no nos diría la
abuela nos diría que para eso no hace
falta internet porque es que internet es
mucho más que eso internet realmente ha
cambiado la forma de relacionarnos yo
estoy convencido que el alimento tim
berners-lee aquí presente junto con
otros visionarios que en su día crearon
tecnología no tenían ni idea de que iba
a ocurrir con la tecnología que ellos
habían inventado de hecho si juntamos la
invención de tim burton así con el
algoritmo trade publicará de privada y
el 3 o 4 más de repente sale el block
change y del bloc se instale pues un
futuro donde probablemente la sociedad
cambie porque va a cambiar la forma en
la que vamos a mover el dinero y hacer
otras muchas cosas seguramente los
tecnólogos como los que diseñaron aquí
nuestro coche volador diseñado los años
50 no imaginaban
cómo iba a ser el futuro porque es que
realmente los que crean tecnologías no
son especialmente buenos viendo qué va a
pasar con su tecnología fijaros qué
curioso que optimistas no tenían
cinturones de seguridad en los coches
voladores
este señor de aquí sale muy joven y
hasta un poco más mayor escribió en 1984
una novela que cambió la ciencia ficción
el premio para que lo conozca para el
que no lo conozca es william gibson
escribió en neuromante y en 1984
escribió una novela en la que hablaba de
internet hablaba de la era virtual y
hablaba de hackers bastante parecido a
como son hoy en día también hablaba
además de esto habla de
megacorporaciones hablaba de
neuro implantes hablaba de inteligencias
artificiales conscientes o sea no como
las que habéis oído hablar de aquí unas
inteligencias artificiales muy muy muy
diferentes lo curioso es que
en 1984 ya existía internet pero no era
algo de uso común y desde luego no era
una cosa que se usara como gibson
hablaba en su libro la real y virtual
pues bueno hablaban de cosas pero
tampoco era una cosa como la que hoy en
día ya se está empezando a ver lo mismo
con los hackers el sitio planteó unas
historias de hackers mucho más creíbles
mucho más parecidas a la realidad
podemos extrapolar las meta
corporaciones las vegas' corporaciones
que son empresas multinacionales con
mucho más poder que cualquier otro país
sobre la tierra no voy a hacer nada malo
de amazon o de google porque eran los
uso pero quizás ese sea el camino lo
mismo que los neurosis es que son un
sistema para conectar la mente con la
máquina de hecho creo que lo más que ha
patentado ya ha cogido el dominio ya ha
creado una empresa se llama neuro link
número estoy inventando lo podéis ver y
las inteligencias artificiales
autoconsciente fuera pues quizá sea el
siguiente camino un comentario es que
gibson obviaba la tecnología escribió
nigromante con una olivetti dos años
sesenta
sin embargo hay científicos que están
empeñados ya lo han dicho aquí pero no
me aspirar el pelo más que stephen
hawking están empeñados en que la
inteligencia artificial puede destruir
la humanidad haber hecho como escritor
soy estoy especializado en distopía
futurista y lo que escribo es ciber pan
que es bastante oscuro y chungo pero la
verdad es que las tesis de stephen
hawking son todavía más oscuras que las
mías en mis libros habrá de hablo del
ciberpunk y sobre todo habla de
inteligencias artificiales que sospecho
que es la razón por la que estoy aquí
el caso es que si tan peligrosa es la
inteligencia artificial y de hecho así
no es la pinta en el cine y todos
conocemos un montón de casos que están
en la izquierda son de películas
pero la realidad es otra muy distinta la
realidad es que la mitad de nosotros
probablemente tenga una aspiradora en
casa que le barre las pelusas debajo de
la cama y no sabemos cómo lo hace y es
fantástico verdad esa inteligencia
artificial bueno vale depp l es para los
que no conozcan es un traductor mucho
mejor que google translator utiliza la
misma tecnología pero lo ha mejorado y
ya es a veces es muy complicado incluso
para traductores profesionales
diferenciar que traducido de pelé y que
traducido un ser humano ya está es real
no me parece demasiado peligroso excepto
si yo fuera traductor alfa 0 es una
aplicación de google que sirve para
barrer literalmente barrer a cualquier
jugador de ajedrez humano o máquina lo
aplasta sistemáticamente lo humilla
google dúplex nos habéis visto el vídeo
yo de verdad os recomiendo verlo es una
demo que hicieron los de google de un
sistema que se supone que era para
reservar restaurantes o citas o cosas no
te sale hay una armas con síntesis de
voz salieron inteligencia artificial
hablando y ahora quiero reservar un
restaurante para ir es equivocada y
hacía bromas y entonces el otro decía
así pues no señor te comienza a las 8 y
tal y lolo flipante la vi lo que me dio
terror es que ellos decían que el que
llamaba era la inteligencia artificial
yo no estaba tan seguro igual el que
recibía la llamada era casi imposible
distinguirlo y eso está ahí hombre yo
sin medicar a eso pues también tendría
un poco de miedo y luego tenemos así que
bueno pues mis hijos con él sería mucho
en suma y por eso empiezo por aquí es
que creo que tenemos en general tenemos
un ídolo que no conocemos y los que
fabrican la tecnología no tienen
realmente mucha idea de cómo va a ser su
uso en el futuro así que la pregunta
debería ser primero antes de hablar de
la inteligencia artificial del futuro
cómo nos va a afectar la inteligencia
artificial mañana o pasado o los
próximos 20 años ya en comentarlo del
estudio club se mancha fago el ejemplo
los salones recreativos para aquellos
jugones como yo pues ya no existe un
salario recreativo ya todos tenemos
consolas y revisores de autobús alguno
se acuerda que había antes un revisor de
tubos que te cobraba el billete y otro
que era conductor quien se acuerda de
eso no existe ha pasado a la historia lo
mismo que los mecanógrafos
bueno pues siento lo siento decir pero a
esta abuela han dicho que el banco su
oficina bancaria para desaparecer y que
tiene que aprender a usar el banco por
internet y esta es la pobre mujer viendo
en el modo diciendo dios mío esto que es
y le han dicho que es eso que hable con
su sobrino que le explique y demás
porque si los bancos como los conocemos
van a desaparecer los coches van a
desaparecer el transporte logístico de
transporte también va a desaparecer las
gasolineras la seguridad el ejército se
va a transformar las bibliotecas cosa
que me duele va a desaparecer todo esto
va a desaparecer ese es el el riesgo que
nos trae la inteligencia artificial que
desaparezcan las recepcionistas no
porque ya ha pasado en un futuro que ha
pasado ya ha pasado en el pasado
vamos a hacer el ejercicio yo sé que iba
hablar del futuro pero no hago más que
dar del pasado pero para hablar del
futuro antes tengo que hablar del pasado
funciona en el micro de lanzamientos
cómo será imaginaros cómo será un futuro
hiperconectado pero primero iros al
siglo 16 imaginaros una oficina cómo
funcionaba allí había un señor en una
silla venían gente ponía papeles encima
la mesa hacia una cosa y hacía otra era
muy sencillo verdad en los bancos en los
años 60 era algo parecido el hombre no
tenía mucho más que una fila de gente
una fila de papeles y hacía una cosa
hasta que así de acuerdo llegar a los 80
y los médicos ya tenían un busca era
algo que les podía interrumpir en
cualquier momento ahí donde estuviera
podría no estar localizables podían no
estar en casa apoyan no están en el
hospital pero en busca de decía que
tienes que ir a operar
y ahora bueno pues imagina nosotros en
el trabajo estáis ahí en el ordenador
que empiezan a salir pantallas que si el
chat corporativo que es el nivel
personal que es el nivel laboral que si
el whatsapp que es el instagram que si
el sms que si el móvil de trabajo el
móvil personal y eso es un follón
infernal pues imaginaros cómo será
dentro de 20 años dentro de 20 años
cuando no sólo todo eso sino que la
lavadora te avise lo que le falta
detergente el baby de tu hijo dice que
está estresado porque tiene un nivel
alto de azúcar y que la profesora les
está gritando demasiado y además tenemos
una en el zapato porque el sensor
nos lo dice y todo todo todo junto junto
junto a la vez imaginaros hacer es un
ejercicio de imaginación de acuerdo esto
va a tener un precio que nosotros
tenemos estos centros de 40 años no
sabemos manejar toda esa tecnología
estaremos totalmente auto
soy escritora ciencia ficción pero bueno
también soy ingeniero lo puedo decir
he programado en más de 20 lenguajes de
programación desde que desde que tenía
esos 15 años y miraba mejor que las
máquinas he trabajado con todos los
sistemas operativos de todos todos igual
no desde que empecé con el espectro en
hasta que acabó trabajando para nike
saché pbx solaris linux y cosas raras
es decir no me considero precisamente
torpe con la tecnología me considero
nativo digital aún aun habiendo nacido
de los años en el año 75 pero yo sé que
dentro de 5 años mi hijo que ahora tiene
5 tenga 10 años
me enseñará a usar los controles ópticos
de la playstation 6 yo dije bueno así
tampoco es tan difícil pero me enseñará
y dentro de 20 él me enseñara usar
alguna tecnología que ahora no podemos
imaginar
habla de la singularidad que básicamente
significa que la tecnología va mucho más
rápido de lo que el ser humano puede
procesar es físico
la biología nuestra está limitada
mientras que la tecnología tiene la
evolución infinita por crecer esta
gráfica básicamente nos dice que dentro
de 50 años la cosa se va a poner muy
loca
básicamente pues vamos a no entender
nada la tecnología va a ir tan rápida
que no vamos a ser capaces de hacer
lo básico y ahí es donde por fin poder
del futuro
vamos a tener que vivir en un futuro
donde tendremos tantas señales de datos
que vamos a necesitar más manos más ojos
más sabores más olores más de todo
porque
otros los tendrán que haber tantas
señales de información que necesitaremos
una ayudita extra necesitaremos que
alguien haga las cosas por nosotros como
ya he dicho por aquí que alguien piense
por nosotros pero no solo que pienses
sino que actúe y cómo va a actuar a
alguien si no tiene datos tendrá que
aprender y qué mejor forma de aprender
que de nosotros desde que nos casamos
cuando probablemente dentro del siglo 23
cuando no marcamos con hadas con bebé le
implanten un chip con un inteligencia
artificial limpia vacía no sepa nada e
ir aprendiendo igual que aprendemos
nosotros será escuchando irá viendo irá
riendo irá jugando se irá cayendo y
sabrá lo que nos gusta y lo que no lo
sabrá mejor que nadie de forma que con
el paso de los años cuando tengamos que
tomar una decisión como del espacio
pesado y no puedo que no puedo quedar
las 10 que esté ocupado y tras algún
restaurante hijo estaría bien que la
próxima semana hiciera todo eso lo hará
por nosotros porque sabrá lo que
queremos nos conocerá mejor que nosotros
mismos de hecho cuando un día en un mal
momento tenemos una mala decisión puede
que nos aconseje una mente fría y
racional que nos diga nativo pero como
has hecho es hombre pero no te das
cuenta que tal y qué cualidades contra
toda nuestra vida por qué
estado allí imaginaros además que esa
inteligencia artificial pasa de padres a
hijos que podemos aprender de la
experiencia de nuestros padres o mejor
aún que se la podemos vender a otro
porque no
la exposición a comercializar lo
importante aquí es que en el siglo 23 la
inteligencia artificial nos permitirá no
estar nunca más solos aunque estemos
solo siempre tendremos un compañero que
nos conoce desde nuestra infancia
esto tendrá un coste
no sé si os lo podéis imaginar habrá
gente que tenga la última tecnología que
tenga la mejor inteligencia artificial
llevar a gente que no tenga ninguna o
tenga un modelo de
y ocurrirá entre los que tengan las
mejores ventajas y los que no tengan
ninguna que habrá una gran brecha habrá
22 civilizaciones o dos culturas que
coexistan el mismo espacio pero no
tengan nada que ver una con otra y
podéis pensar que exagera un poco pero
pensad ahora mismo en todo lo que sabéis
vosotros sabéis moveros por internet y
sabéis usar un smartphone sabes usar
internet hay gente no hace falta que
sean mayores hay gente que no tiene
acceso a esa tecnología o que no ha
aprendido o por la razón que sea no
puede y la diferencia entre unos y otros
ya es enorme imaginaros que ocurrirá en
el siglo 23 cuando uno es que te tiene
una consciencia avanzada e implementada
en su ser compiten contra aquellos que
son simplemente animales biológicos
puede que en el futuro la inteligencia
artificial desarrolle su propio alma
quizás en ese proyecto
en ese proceso el ser humano haya
perdido la suya
a mí la tecnología a mí la inteligencia
artificial no es lo que me da miedo
también me da más miedo el ser humano
que la tecnología el inventor de la
dinamita ya ya avisaba decía cuidado que
con esto lo podemos liar parda podemos
acabar con el mundo einstein lo dijo con
la energía nuclear
y ahora pues estaré lo más que hay
diciendo que la inteligencia artificial
para acabar con el mundo bueno pues hay
un patrón la tecnología
puede que la energía nuclear acabe con
nosotros pero también puede que nos dé
otra singularidad diferente de la
inteligencia artificial energía gratis
ilimitada
merece la pena probar
los escritores como yo soñamos un futuro
que otros llevarán a cabo pero porque no
somos profetas pero si hoy os he hecho
soñar se hecho reflexionar aunque solo
sea un poquito
ahora ha merecido la pena porque el
futuro pertenece a los soñadores muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]